il voulait rester une majorité de
français voulait le garder mais après
trois ans à la tête du gouvernement
c'est fini je suis très heureux de vous
accueillir dans cet hôtel de matignon
jean castex prend donc le relais
une autre pays qui a traversé cette
crise sanitaire qui a traversé d'autres
crises a besoin d'un esprit ouvert et
d'une main ferme une conclusion à
laquelle edouard philippe arrive après
un mandat marqué par les crises gilet
jaune grève des transports réforme des
retraites contesté puis crise sanitaire
sans précédent
c'est une lourde tâche qui incombe
aujourd'hui à jean castex
un homme de 55 ans jusqu'ici méconnue du
grand public c'est lui qui a tout
récemment pilote il déconfinement de la
france en sait quelque chose
la crise économique et sociale elle est
déjà là et il nous faudra plus que
jamais réunir la nation pour lutter
contre cette crise qui s'installe
soyez bon
et comme on dit chez moi bon vent c'est
sur ces mots qu'un edouard philippe
visiblement ému a cédé sa place à
l'hôtel de matignon jean castex n'a
jamais été ministre mais pour le
président emmanuel macron le maire de la
petite ville de prades dans les pyrénées
orientales et haut fonctionnaire de
carrière cumule deux avantages celui de
connaître les rouages de
l'administration publique tout en
projetant une image familière pour une
france qui se sentent déconnectés du
pouvoir celle des régions du territoire
ce proche de l'ancien président nicolas
sarkozy est un homme de droite assumé en
fait il ressemble étrangement à edouard
philippe
avec une différence notable souligne
qu'une majorité d'analystes aujourd'hui
jean castex ne risque pas de faire
d'ombré à son président emmanuel main
comprend du coup un grand risque à se
séparer d'edouard philippe parce que il
convenait à la fois aux français parce
que s'il incarnait ce centre droit qui
est devenu le socle électoral d'emmanuel
macron et puis emmanuel macro prend
grand risque parce que se séparer la
premier ministre populaire ça n'a pas
toujours réussi à ses prédécesseurs
la cérémonie de passation des pouvoirs
entre les deux hommes aura été d'une
rare chaleur pour ce genre d'événement
forcé après des hommages et des
remerciements mutuelle si sous les
applaudissements nourris
empreint de bienveillance qu'edouard
philippe a quitté matignon pour de bon
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris